I can I catch it by psychobabble um I'd
say I'm but a bigot what are we gonna
say to that oh [ __ ] cats are cats all
I'm sure how the [ __ ] I go that's
thought okay uh what mashups how I dad
today let's see the scuffle these are
always kind of fun okay got one more
huge scene to film and this one's gonna
be so tough I'm pointing a new phrase
for it exaggerated yeah I don't want to
spoil the surprise but trust me holy
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is going on here did
you say that with that building up Rob
yeah jay says just had a cur ship
sucks that I that I got I got it through
a guy I got there I betcha oh I am a
stunt pilot
yeah a sick [ __ ] slow I get real our
hello anyways how was your day wretches
how's your [ __ ] how's your day
I got guy like most times out of ten I
came a long shot but you're my buddy oh
yes okay is this
ok
yeah sure
it is
where you i'm at i get where you want me
to go
okay [ __ ] out here okay you're ready
to crush this final sequence you have to
stop the mind control transfers like a
flu virus in it you're gonna fly the
spaceship giggles script says you're the
pilot and gunner so you know how to fly
this right that's service that never
stops me and the locations of the
transmitters check the nav computer you
really know your stuff most of the time
I just wing it actually wish I was more
like that honey you got the makings of a
great Saint you just need a little here
we go action cumana I'll destroy the
shield generator to open our link to the
transmitter it all upload the virus a
week oh okay that is it differently it
ended differently than the scrip says
that's okay you have to stop the mind
control transmitters by uploading virus
into them they're gonna get to fly the
spaceship getting it going Rick says
yours pilot and gunner
so you know how to find us right no but
that never stops me and the locations of
the transmitter okay okay I'll destroy
the shield generator to open a link to
the transmitter and all upload the virus
so we can shut these all down won't that
kill your a bull yes with their minds
still connected to the hive they too
will die listen us why isn't it blowing
it up okay I guess it is destroyed it
uploading the virus now I'll keep us
safe don't worry the value that fan I
always defer a couple pitches out there
is it
that shet
that's it that cat has a phoner again
but I love complete two more to go who
is calling right my god good earth lines
watch emotional death it's really
captured the plate of the whole planet
their emotional what but you Jackie look
my name's Jenny and yeah I know what you
think can we just get to the next scene
now I want jobs that ship doing cool
things you know find my buildings
through narrow areas [ __ ] like that
let's see what you can really do it ND
yeah I guess don't worry
as got it it's got it
chef chef
ah [ __ ]
oh oh oh oh it's a funny [ __ ]
we can use that ok fly through the
bridge okay
you
oh [ __ ]
great shot yes and I'm a problem bro
much credit huh that's pretty great back
there John yeah well he deserved it
don't they always still thanks for the
encouragement hey i just pointed you in
the right direction he did the rest on
your own okay okay switching beds
okay okay
okay go to the second chance matter
can't you say I'm doing that you don't
go that far
the second generator you know what to do
yeah I gotta go higher up
yeah uploading hey should I swing around
so the camera can get a better angle of
this [ __ ] extras with all the other
actresses in this film are gonna do it
okay oh sorry not in terrain just what
they always say
or any other
and make a double
Oh shet sir uploads done good job with
that what the hell's that mean it's
coming up soon just make it work that
their way yeah awake uh-oh what the
hell's going on either the military
doesn't know this is a movie you just
hired them to attack us kill them all of
course chef
now let's say I'm beginning to think jen
is gonna get us killed I'm with you on
that
let's do those [ __ ]
ok that's chef
rolling this is the last chilled one
sits down in the viruses in will be able
to end this
it's so much faster do that beginning
the upload you know something I'm not
sure those ships are remote-controlled
what would you expect was easier to use
the extra supply these things saves
money and they were just expendable
workers anyway so then they're really
trying to kill us [ __ ] killing real
people for a movie oh what is that oh
Footloose helicoptered cost
ah [ __ ] anything except my camera group
that's sorry man
where the [ __ ] is the other one
oh I'm not in range
okay where is the other [ __ ] is the
other helicopter
is it like stuck
sometime stop came up all right now you
have to get to the center of the city to
execute the fire okay okay let's say
that instead of the sooner we're done
with this scene the sooner I can go home
and let off some steam nice hot bath a
drive through a crowded Street doing 100
miles per hour both are good stress
relief that is this why are we here okay
we're here set off the viruses executing
that solicit down what did you do queen
Lana your ship is shutting down while in
range of the virus is down I want one
more stuff one more close flyby only
faster with more intensity this will be
the best scene in the bed you're gonna
kill it
[ __ ]
this ain't gettin [ __ ] wobbly it's
like hard to control
[ __ ] escape the signal radius are you
serious we won't get close to death
we'll get blown to hell [ __ ] that we're
getting out of here okay that's gonna
ask a DA let's say these final lines and
get off this damn ship yeah sure Oh Cat
Cat Cat Cat game guys kick your this
safe for now stupid
stupid ass what the [ __ ] is happening up
there you're goddamn right we kill it
Simba [ __ ] Oh God
oh honey you're
you're gonna crazy eyes again
Jenny talk to me yeah Jenny tired I'm
tired of him
I'm tired of it stupid [ __ ] dark okay
seems a little extreme though you might
you tuck
oh wow
you're killing it
wow so this has a rep well well Todd
well done know what thanks for watching
boys thank ya
it's out for Harambee